ferrand toute la zone est modifié pour
vous en rendre compte
regardez ces images les premières qu'ils
aient pû être tournées à bord d'un
hélicoptère depuis la catastrophe et qui
permettent donc de se rendre compte de
la modification du quartier manhattan le
quartier des affaires
avant et après commentaires philippe
gassot elle faisait face à la liberté
lune éclairait les autres reflétait
tourner vers le sud jusque dans les
nuages avec 107 étages 11 septembre 2001
plus rien et descendre un trou un
quartier d'affaires
les sociétés financières assurances
avocat 2 millions d'employés
le premier survol en hélicoptère donne
l'étendue des dégâts
c'est l'apocalypse maintenant
symbole de réussite premières places
financières 410 m
pour ceux qui voudraient se souvenir les
deux tours étaient là entre ces deux
images un peu de fumée grise et au moins
5000 bord